[Music]
hi everyone its Alisa Malone welcome to
another episode of fandango indie movie
guide this week I'm coming to you from
can in France for the Cannes Film
Festival I've been seeing a bunch of
movies I've been here for five days now
I've watched 16 films and I'm going to
tell you about my five favorites that
I've seen here at the fest let's start
with number 5 how to talk to girls at
parties this is directed by John Cameron
Mitchell and it's based on a short story
by Neil Gaiman it's about this group of
aliens there's six alien colonies in
total they come to earth to do a little
tour and Elle Fanning plays one of the
aliens chance at meeting this young boy
who's really into punk music if you want
to learn all about Punk it's a really
sweet film all about first love and
conformity vs freedom I never thought
that an alien punk
comedy could have so much human heart at
its center but I think that's down to
John Cameron Mitchell definitely look
out for how to salsa girls at parties it
is wonderfully weird don't start this
Punk do more Punk to me
number four is Reggie table by Michel
Hazanavicius the same director who did
the artist this time he takes on
jean-luc Godard the cinematic genius the
leader of the French New Wave someone
who was so influential here and can and
around the world
dr. Michael circle clinically so I
willing to blow a blow but it definitely
not in the market I think the focus of
the photovoltaic so play there's only
about yeah it's not the nicest character
in this film but if you love cinema and
particularly if you love gods are there
plenty ville Easter eggs lots of shots
that taken from goods are film so much
fun to watch very self referential
little bit Woody Allen ask in the way
that it breaks the fourth wall and Louis
Gorrell does a wonderful job of playing
jean-luc Godard and Stacy Martin is
perfectly cast and I want all of our
costumes selected one on excel to
decorated at social point number three
is another movie which mentions John
Luke Raja is called is our village or
faces places its documentary starring
Agnes Varda he was female directed
during the French New Wave and the
photographer JR these two have teamed up
the old and the new and they traveled
around to different villages in France
they met people they heard their story
took photos of them and then pasted
giant pictures of those photos on all
the buildings it's really sweet when you
see people's reactions to seeing their
photo on such a large scale and it's
also really nice to look back at Agnes's
career and forward at Jr's career they
work so well together they have mutual
respect
they're both great artists and at the
end they go to visit John Lieber done
Jeffie number two is a Swedish movie
called the swear directed by Ruben
ozland who did force majeure a couple
years ago this has some of the same
sense of humor very dark comedy that one
was about what happens when you in an
emergency do you try to save your family
or if you try to save yourself this one
the square is all about what happens
when you are asked for help do you give
that help freely do you question what
it's about and then what happens when
you have to ask for help it has so many
layers in there so many things to delve
into so many conversations to be had
after the movie wickedly funny also very
disturbing I think it takes a deft hand
to make you laugh one second and then be
shocked the next Ruben Auslan does that
brilliantly great task too including
Elizabeth moss and Dominic West how
often would you say that you take women
so you don't know very well and have sex
with them do you not remember them yeah
sure I do yeah you know their names
yeah yeah always always yeah yeah so
what's my name and my favorite film here
at the Cannes Film Festival my
number-one choice might have some people
questioning me because it's also one of
the darkest films that's flowing here
it's called the killing of a sacred deer
by yoga slam Thomas he's the director
that did the lobster and dogtooth this
is probably even the darkest of all of
his movies and it's the one that's set
in the most realistic world it's about a
doctor played by Colin Farrell who gets
terrorized by this young boy and he ends
up having to make this horrible Sophie's
Choice this is like watching a
slow-motion car accident where you can't
look away but it's so traumatic to see
with it satisfying as well and for me I
just love a movie that makes you
challenge makes you feel something even
if it's uncomfortable I left to the
screening and haven't stopped thinking
about the film plus I kind of felt like
I needed a shot of tequila and a shower
very very disturbing but great cast
Nicole Kidman plays the wife she does a
brilliant job and yoga plants thermos I
think is one of the best directors
working today because he has such a
unique vision he's such an original
voice you can tell that it's one of his
films it's got his stab all over it and
I highly recommend just giving an open
mind to the killing of a sacred deer
this is the kind of movie that people
will love or they will absolutely hate I
loved it totally my damn my mom's going
to be upset can I tell you a secret
don't tell her I told you I think she I
think she likes you I mean she's
attracted to you but she says that's not
true but it is I'm sure and to be honest
I think you're perfect for each other
you'd make a great couple
today you have it five of my favorite
films playing here at the Cannes Film
Festival also want to give a quick shout
out to happy end by McHale Chanukah
another traumatic movie also okra and
the male witch stories two films that
are going to be available on Netflix
very soon
I'm Alicia Malone you can catch up with
me on Twitter at Alicia Malone I'll see
you soon
[Music]